so clearly it's too late to do anything
about the Chinese military aircraft that
just hovered over some of our nuclear
launch sites but some members of
Congress are taking the threat from
China seriously Congressman Chris Smith
of New Jersey is one of them he is the
chairman of a new bipartisan China
commission he just introduced a bill to
strip China of trade privileges he's
also introduced legislation to remove
trade offices in the U.S that are
effectively controlled by China seems
obvious that every Republican in the
chamber would support this do you think
they will we're about to find out
Congressman Chris Smith joins us tonight
Congressman thank you so much for coming
on pretty straightforward thank you
piece of legislation from what I can
tell are we going to strip China of its
trade privileges how many I think we
members are supporting this
well we're building a group we've talked
I've talked to a lot of people uh and
we're going to get co-sponsors and a lot
of them you know back in May 26 1994
President Bill Clinton severed uh the
relationship between human rights and
trade and that's when we lost China
that's when we lost it that's when they
said all as they care about is profits
and then came the multilateral
corporations to make money hand over
fists exploiting the local Workforce
under Xi Jinping they've gone from bad
to extremely worse as a you know a the
uyghurs are being subjected to genocide
religious freedom is being decimated all
over China so the oppressor and that Xi
Jinping the Chinese companies party are
horribly oppressing the people of China
Taiwan could be next and certainly Hong
Kong now has been largely lost so our
bill says Bill Clinton you had it right
when you were saying there ought to be
linkage between human rights and trade
I'm taking in that whole template and
saying we need to do it and we need to
do it now you know China is an exporting
Nation as you know so well without
exports that economy drives to a dribble
we need to say unless you make seriously
sustained progress in ending torture
political prisoners concentration camps
forced abortion all the horrible things
I just had a hearing in July Tucker on
this horrible practice of of stealing
people's organs 50 to 100 000 people 100
000 victims every year who are killed to
get their organs and they go after 28
years old that's the that's that's what
was brought out in our hearing and it's
from people like Christians in tibetan
Buddhists uyghurs and the falun gong
practitioners I this is something that
is nazi-like and is going on right now
so we're saying they have to clean up
their act or else their ability to send
their exports to U.S markets will be
severely and substantially uh tariffed
and that's what this bill does
meanwhile people like Larry Flink with
Larry finka BlackRock suck up the
Chinese the middle of the genocide then
lecture us on George Floyd I bet you
this is probably the only lever that
could get any changed all in our
relationship with China and of course we
wish you the best of luck you're gonna
need it Congressman Chris thank you and
it will make a difference it will make a
difference had Clinton not de-linked
human rights from trade we would have a
different China today that's when we
lost them and intellectual property
rights are also included in our bill
they have to stop stealing our secrets
yeah the one thing they care about is
trade for sure thank you congressman
thank you so much Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight